I think you need more sleep than me.
I'm starting my next stream now.
I started my...
I accidentally...
It's fine.
I started my stream.
I started my next stream.
I...
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, have fun live.
Sorry guys, I accidentally raided this stream.
I accidentally raided.
Oh my god.
Alright, we're doing the...
Should we chat our stuff first or should we raid now?
Should we do the pillaging?
We probably don't need to do the pillaging.
Hold on, I have so many DMs real quick.
Hold on.
Okay, guys, I accidentally raided Minstream instead of my own stream.
Hold on, I have so many DMs.
Hold on.
Okay, okay.
Ugh.
Someone said the pillager is not worth the risk.
Okay, let's just enchant stuff then.
You work on enchanting.
I'm just gonna work on...
Um, do you want the...
I'll put the enderpearls in your chest.
And then I'll put the books in your...
Do you want me to make bookshelves now?
I can make it now.
Um, hold on.
Oh god, wait.
How many bookshelves do we need?
Um, I don't know.
Guys, how many do we need for the enchanting table?
Oh yeah, how many do we need?
You have more.
You can get past the books to me and I'll make them.
Yeah, I have that many.
15.
Oh my god!
Okay, we have enough.
Yeah, we have so many.
15?
Okay, we have...
But we still need books for...
For the enchanting stuff.
So...
Oh, I see it.
Okay, 15.
So, we have 9 right now.
I'm gonna go farm some more trees real quick.
Oh, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep!
I'mma sleep in my bed.
I'mma sleep too.
I'mma sleep as well.
Guys, we have one life.
If we don't do this, it's over.
We'll try this again another time.
Try what?
What are we trying?
If we fuck it up.
We have one life to make this happen.
One life to make what happen?
What's happening?
The Ender Dragon.
We have one life.
We have one life to make this work.
Oh, chat is frozen.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for letting...
I forgot to change my chat overlay as well.
Thank you, me too.
Sorry guys, we just came right back into it.
We just came right back.
One life to make it all work.
Ender Dragon.
Alright.
Okay, I got the wood.
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
I got enough for...
I think I got enough for bookshelves.
Yeah, I do.
I do.
We got this.
Wood.
And then I should have...
I should have enough for 15.
Let's see.
Bookshelf.
You know what I think might happen?
What?
I won't be surprised if...
Just there.
What?
What do you mean by that?
Just there.
Do you think we're gonna die?
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
We're not.
We can do this.
Oh, we need glass.
So I need to get...
Sand.
Sand is right next to us.
Oh, what's the glass for?
The potion bottles?
Yeah.
Is that what else you need to make?
Potion bottles.
I haven't unlocked it, so I don't know yet.
I think that's it.
I think it's just glass.
Oh, we just need to get glass, and then...
We had so many empty bottles, too.
And we threw it all away.
It's fine.
We didn't need it.
Okay.
It's fine.
But they don't stack.
So it sucks.
That's true.
13.
14.
I have 15.
And we have 38 books, too.
15.
Yeah, I'll put the bookshelves...
I'll put the bookshelves with you.
Okay.
I can help you with glass, too.
What else do I need for the bottle?
Oh, I need to make the glass.
Give me the shovel.
I'll get glass, and then you can work on enchanting table and stuff.
Do you have any...
Coal?
I do.
It's in my other box.
It's in my other chest.
Give me the glass, and I'll...
I'll dig, like...
Dig the sand, and then you work on enchanting table.
Okay.
Alright.
I mean, sand is literally right here.
Yeah, just get some.
Yeah, just grab some.
Oh, I need to make space for the...
We're being...
We're teamwork.
Teamwork.
Teamwork right here.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
Right here.
Okay.
I got...
46.
I think 46 is enough.
Probably, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll start burning the glass.
Yeah.
Burn it up, baby.
Burn it up.
Does the blast furnace work with sand?
I don't think so.
Wait, does it not?
No, it does not.
Okay.
Someone said, what if the end portal is 12 blocks...
12k blocks away?
Don't say that.
There's no way.
We don't have Elijah's?
Don't say that.
Please.
If it's too far, we're calling it.
We're going in here.
So we just need the 15 bookshelves around, right?
Okay, that's all it is.
Yeah, just surround it.
Okay, I'm making this stuff.
Just like that, right, guys?
I think so, yeah.
Like that.
And you put the...
Thing in the middle, yeah.
Is it?
Did it work?
Yeah, now we need the lapis.
Not the corners?
It's fine.
I have...
Here, let me see it.
62.
How many levels do you have?
Um...
30?
35?
You can get knockback...
Yeah, it goes all the way to 3.
Enchantment, knockback...
Smite...
Here's...
I can enchant the bow, actually.
Power!
I should get that, right, for the bow?
That's for the bow, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll put that for the bow then, right?
Right?
Is that right, guys?
Oh yeah, infinity on the bow would be so good.
Okay.
Also, it goes to unbreaking 3.
So we're good, guys.
I have power 4 on my bow.
Should I do unbreaking on my sword?
I can't remember what the enchantments are.
I can just...
I'm just gonna...
If we have a bad...
If we have bad luck...
Where's the rest of the books?
Here, I put the rest of the books here.
Okay, we can just put some...
On your right side.
Yeah, I got them.
We can just reset with this.
I need anvil.
You have all my iron, right?
Oh yeah, here you go.
Oh, blast protection!
That's good, that's good.
Hold on.
Here you go.
There you go.
Oh, 32.
That's enough for an anvil.
Oh, armor enchant.
Yeah, thank you, guys.
Armor enchant.
Anvil...
Wait, how do I make an anvil?
Blast protection 4 is good, right?
No, it's not good.
Wait, feather falling.
We need feather falling.
Oh, let me check my boots.
How do I make anvil again?
Iron blocks?
How many do I need?
Yeah, you need some iron blocks.
Okay, 3.
Okay, I have enough.
3.
Oh.
Oh, I do.
I just had enough.
That's good.
Alright.
I just had enough for an anvil.
Flat protection is best.
Okay.
I only have protection 1.
Okay, what else can we get?
Let's try our helmet instead.
6.
I'm breaking, I'm breaking.
Projectile protection.
Fix my bow.
Yeah, let's check the bow.
Let's try the bow.
Power 4.
Power 4 would be good on the bow, right?
Yeah, it would be good.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, I also got extra unbreaking on it.
Cool.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I need to take my shoes off.
Okay, cool.
Deathstrider.
Oh, projectile protection.
Just explain how I'm too tired to think.
Projectile...
I don't know, do we need...
No, just say...
They all said normal protection is better than projectile.
Yeah, but my thing doesn't make that.
Well, just do something else.
And then you can unlock...
Unbreaking 3.
Well, I got protection 3 on my boots.
That should be good.
Unbreaking 3.
Oh, I don't have...
Protect 3.
Okay, thanks, guys.
Where's my pants?
Unbreaking 3, protection 2.
Oh, I have protection 2.
I'm gonna get protection 2.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I can't do more on my boots.
No, we don't have enough XP.
We should be fine, right?
What XP do you need?
Oh, I don't...
Oh, I need...
Sharpness and sweeping edge.
Let me see what I have.
How do I combine?
What do I do?
You put...
I didn't realize my glasses were on.
What glasses?
No, I have protection 3 for my chest.
I need that.
You have sharpness?
Oh, I'm just gonna get sharpness.
Fuck it, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna kill something.
It might be me.
What do I have on my head?
Fire protection, respiration.
Why are they all such shitty levels?
Okay.
I'm just gonna commit with these.
I think this is fine.
How should I get some more levels, guys?
How do you get more levels really fast?
Do I have more on my feet?
I'm breaking 3, fire protection.
I'm breaking 3.
We gotta sleep.
Okay, I'm just checking my chestplate real fast.
Mining quartz in the nether.
You guys are funny.
You guys are so funny.
We're not going back.
I'll kill fish.
Don't make us go back there.
I'll kill fish, it's fine.
We're gonna fucking go crazy.
Don't make us go back into the nether.
Mining coal.
Where can I find some coal?
Don't do that.
Min and I are two different types of sleeping.
You're just... you're fatigued.
I'm just delusional.
Oh my god, there's dogs!
I can't get to the...
Oh my gosh, but the dogs went to home.
I can kill a bunch of animals.
Kill.
I'm in my kill era.
I also, we have the leather books.
Leather and paper for books too.
Oh yeah.
But we have like 30.
We already have a lot of books now.
But just in case we're like trying really to get like feather falling or something.
Well that's true.
To like refresh the enchantments, right?
Yeah, or something.
What do I want to get?
My bones.
Okay.
It's 4.30 and you're dying?
Insane.
I'm already dead.
I can't die anymore.
That's why it's just an actual hell for me.
You're just in hell.
I'm just in hell.
Because I'm done.
I want to die, but I can't die.
What are you doing?
You can't die again.
Oh, there's a dog.
We didn't die those three times.
Wait, there's two dogs here.
Yeah, I'm trying to get them right now.
I'm trying to get those two dogs.
I'm trying to get them in my fucking army.
They will be the clutch.
This dog took four of my...
Oh my god.
Okay, this one's not picky.
Oh, there's coal here, but there's a zombie too.
You're not picky.
Wait, you're gonna die here.
That's so happy.
You know what?
I'm ready.
I'm ready to go.
Ready to go where?
I'm ready to find the stronghold.
I'm so ready, man.
I'm ready to go in.
We're not gonna win.
We won't live.
Yes, we will.
If we don't, we won't live.
We won't live.
You don't know that.
You said that we're going another two or three hours.
What happened?
I feel so strong.
I feel so strong now.
How?
What did you do?
I don't know.
I just feel something in me.
I'm locked in.
We're gonna kill those...
I'm gonna kill those fucking...
I'm locking in.
I'm locking in with my aimbot.
I'm gonna lock in.
I'm gonna hit those towers.
And then it's gonna be so easy.
I've done it before.
I can do it again.
I can...
I'm not delusional.
I swear to God.
I'm not...
I'm not delusional.
I can hit those...
I can hit those blocks.
It's gonna be so easy to hit them.
I'm not delusional.
I swear it's gonna be so easy.
Delulu is the solulu.
I'm not the Lulu.
I know I'm not.
I am.
I'm a Lulu.
I am blue Lulu.
Oh my gosh, I mined so much and I didn't even get anything.
Wait, what dogs are you trying to get?
I already got them.
I got the two dogs.
There's two more dogs over here.
How many fucking dogs are there?
I don't have another bone though.
I already got my bone.
Are we mining the quartz?
Are we?
No, we're not.
I'm going in.
Oh yeah, we have to get a lot of levels, don't we?
Wait, I'm going in.
Don't go in, Mint.
Don't go in.
This is the one.
I'm going in.
How did you get...
How did you get the obsidian?
We have one more.
Don't come with me, dogs.
Where I'm going, I don't know if I'm coming back.
Where I'm going...
I'll take care of you if she dies.
Where I'm going, I don't know.
I need to go back.
I forgot to bring my gold armor.
Oh, the gold armor.
Get me back in.
Why isn't it getting me back in?
I almost didn't make it back.
Wait, there's gold nuggets here.
Where's my gold chest?
No, that's the gold armor I threw away.
Okay, it's fine.
I can make a helmet.
I can make a helmet real quick.
There we go.
Give me all your phantom membranes.
I got my one phantom membrane.
It's in here.
Where I'm going, I don't know if I'm coming back.
If you don't come back, then we're dead.
Wait, what do you mean you're one phantom membrane?
There's nothing in here.
It's in your other chest.
No, it's not.
There's only two chests here.
I took it back.
I accidentally took it back.
It's back in my inventory.
Why did you do that?
I'm coming back.
I'm here.
Put it back.
I put it back.
Thanks, I got it.
I'm going back again.
Where's the redstone?
It's in your other chest.
I got it.
To make this...
Where's the glass?
We got the glass.
We can make a bottle.
I'm at level 26.
They do stack.
Oops.
They don't stack when there's stuff in it.
That's basically it.
You just gotta...
I put the powder in here.
How much levels should I get?
Where is it in here?
The exciting stuff in here.
We need the water.
How many what?
How many levels?
I'm at level 26 now.
Get as many as you can.
I'll get as many.
Just let me know when to come back.
When you're done with everything else...
Then I'll come back.
I'm just gonna keep farming until you're done with everything else.
Okay.
And then every other prep stuff.
And then we just go.
But I also need to get levels.
Okay.
When you're done...
When I get to 30, we swap.
Swap.
I'm gonna leave some quartz for you.
I'm leaving some easy quartz.
I'm gonna go for the harder ones.
How do I make the eye of the ender?
Oh, do I make it...
The blaze rods thing first?
Or...
We have the blaze rods.
Oh my god, I have blaze rods.
I'm coming back down.
Oh my god, you just took everything.
I did!
I did take everything!
I just never had it in my inventory.
I...
Oh, cook the quartz for XP?
That's what they're for?
Yeah, the quartz are for XP.
That's all we...
Oh, I thought they meant farming them.
I thought they just meant farming them.
I didn't realize cooking them.
What is this BGM?
This is my mental state right now.
My BGM.
That's how I feel right now.
I don't know how the others...
Are you listening to the...
Fart...
Competition too?
What?
What are you talking about?
What are you...
The song!
It says your BGM!
I could put it on if you guys would listen to it.
That's the...
Wait, you can cook the quartz?
Oh my god, I got one guy.
They were like...
Okay, I gave you my blaze rods.
The blaze rods are in.
And I put emerald.
I think that's... And I put all the lapis stuff.
I'm going back in.
Oh, we have to pick it up with silk touch.
We don't have that!
Oh wait, it's here.
I have the song, you guys.
Here you go.
This is the fart competition.
Alright.
When I hit 30, I'll let you farm the other quartz.
I think we need...
We need a minimum so we can have one more...
30 would be like one more enchantment that we get to have on level 30.
There's so many quartz.
Thank god there's so many quartz.
Up we go.
Oh my god, it's over here.
It's over here.
You're alive, okay?
You're alive.
Sorry, I was jamming to the music.
Okay.
Oh shit, we gotta sleep.
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm coming back.
Wait, can you sleep if I'm in the nether?
No, you have to be sleeping too.
Okay, I'm coming back.
I'm coming back.
I'm heading back right now.
I'm running, I'm fucking running over.
I think their dogs won't protect me either.
They hate me.
I'm running back, I'm fucking running.
You wanna swap over so you can farm the quartz?
I left a lot of quartz to the right.
Uh, I need the gold stuff.
Okay, I got it.
I'm sleeping.
I'm here.
I just don't wanna kill the pigs.
I feel like I'm gonna fucking die if I do.
I need it here, I dropped some gold for you.
Oh, you can sleep while the other person is in the nether?
Oh, okay.
You dropped some wood for me?
Oh, thank you.
Guys, I feel like if I try to kill the pigmen, I will die.
Guys, I will 100% die if I try to kill them.
There's no way, there's no way I will live.
There's no way.
Okay.
What happened?
Wait, I'm coming back, I'm coming back!
You let the pigmen come into my house!
She's not gonna hurt you!
She literally came out swinging a sword!
Wait, why?
And now he's a zombie.
I don't know why.
How did he...
How did we have an invader?
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna do something really crazy.
He's a zombie now, it's okay.
I'm gonna do something...
I'm gonna do something very crazy.
Okay guys, we're gonna make potions.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try and kill these pigs.
For XP.
What pigs?
Oh, the regular pigmen?
Yeah, I'm gonna do it.
Oh, I mean I can kill this guy.
Yeah, kill him.
Take his stuff, take his stuff.
Oh my god, here's some gold stuff too.
Yeah, thanks.
Perfect.
Okay, I'm gonna do something very crazy.
I'm gonna put a spectral arrow.
And then...
Okay, so I first do the nether wart, right?
I do the wart...
And then I do...
Okay, I'm...
Yes.
This might be how I die.
Do I put it in here or in here?
Then the membrane.
Okay.
This could be how I die.
Wait, there's a lot of pigmen.
Maybe I'm not gonna do this.
Actually, let me see if I can find quartz.
Or membrane redstone.
I'll put it...
Where's the quartz I saw here?
Oh, I have to fuel it with the blaze powder.
Oh, okay.
Thanks, guys.
Alright.
Yeah, you guys, I realized how bad of an idea that was.
I'm already in too deep.
I'm already...
Alright.
You're doing it.
I have levels.
I'm level 30.
You can go and farm some quartz if you need to.
I'm gonna make a trail for you to follow.
Follow this trail.
To farm quartz for levels.
Goop, goop, goop.
I made a torch trail.
Follow it.
And then you'll find lots of quartz around you.
Now the membrane.
I got it.
I made a torch trail for you.
Is it working?
Or do I need the blaze powder too?
I need the blaze powder.
Okay.
Where is it cooking?
I'm here.
Oh, next to the redstone.
I'm gonna check for...
Did it work?
Don't mine the gold.
Just remember not to mine the gold.
But it's not long.
It's not long.
Wait, but it's only a minute and 30.
Oh, redstone now.
Okay, okay.
Okay, now redstone.
Okay, thank you guys.
There we go.
Okay.
We're doing it.
I need to reset.
How do I reset again?
Do I just put a book in here?
Is that it?
Yeah, you have to reset your gacha with something else.
Like with my book, right?
Yeah, I think so.
And it resets all three?
Yeah.
You have all the other books.
Oh, I have books.
Yeah, here you go.
Can you pass me?
And the lapis.
Here you go.
Lapis.
Awkward potions.
Wait, I need the blaze powder here.
Oh wait, wait, wait.
I'm scared.
I'll do this then.
Reset level one.
It's still power.
Oh, okay.
Now I go back to...
Wait, what do I get then?
Not until the fuel runs out.
Oh, I see.
Fire protection, blast protection 2.
Oh, blast protection 2.
We're doing it.
The blaze rod should last us a while then.
Blast protection.
Oh, blast protection 4.
Oh, nice.
There's a blast protection 4 here.
Okay.
Alright.
Ouchie, ouchie.
Okay.
Back in there we go.
I almost forgot.
No, you don't want the blast protection.
You want regular protection.
Oh.
I keep forgetting.
Okay, so I have to reset again.
Oh.
And then we do a redstone.
I don't want to just hold on to it.
Okay.
How many levels do you need for...
What level are you now?
29.
But I'm about to be at 0.
How are you about to be 0?
Because I want to put the protection on my chest.
No, it just takes a couple of levels.
It doesn't take the whole thing.
Oh.
Yeah.
Nevermind.
It just takes a couple.
Okay, where are the other quartz?
Oh my god.
At the membrane.
Where are the other quartz?
Oh, not the soul sand.
Why is the soul sand right next to us?
I need like one more.
Okay.
Two more.
I'll leave this for you.
What do you leave it for me?
Don't you need them for farm?
What is it?
What do you leave it?
What do I need the farm for?
Levels.
Oh.
Don't you need the levels?
Yeah.
One life.
One life, guys.
If we don't make it here, it's over.
We'll do this next time.
When we're not...
When we're more prepared.
I watched the video.
But it was...
It's not...
We would take us...
Tokyo, it wasn't us!
It wasn't us!
It was the...
It was the fortress!
It wasn't even our fault.
It's the fortress.
It was the force...
It was the fucking fortress.
We could have fucking finished this so long ago.
With the fucking fortress.
Okay, protection tube, blast protection, I could get...
Where am I at?
Wait, the membrane.
Do I just put protection on it?
Do I might as well just put protection?
Or do I... I don't want to reset again.
I feel like...
Just protection.
I feel like if I reset, it's just going to be a waste.
Chat, do I reset?
I'll just get this.
I'll just get the radio protection.
Okay.
Restore.
Oh shit, okay.
I feel like if I just... Yeah, I don't want to... I'm not going to... Okay, and then...
Okay, and then that should reset the others too, right?
Protection 4!
Let's go!
Okay, helmet protection 4.
And then B is also protection 4.
Okay, I'll get the helmet.
Okay, we got all the slow falling, so hopefully that's enough.
Nice.
Alright, you can go grind some quartz first because I've been hogging the quartz.
Hold on, I gotta make more potions.
Okay.
Alright, I'll go check if I can find other ways to grind.
Get... I'll just go for the harder quartz to find.
I can do... I'll just go for the harder places to find quartz so I don't take the easy ones.
I made torches halfway through to get the easy ones for quartz, so...
This should be fine.
Okay.
So...
We're not... We're not gonna... We're not gonna... Guys, we're not...
We're not... We can't, guys.
We can't cook quartz.
We got lied to before and it doesn't work.
Cooking quartz doesn't work.
It's all fake news.
What if I'm a cooking quartz?
It said you can cook quartz, but you have to use silk touch the quartz to cook them.
Who?
What?
I've never heard that.
Copper on furnace can give you good XP.
Oh, put copper in furnace.
We have a lot of copper.
We don't need fire resist, but it breathes fire.
Oh, regen potion.
Okay.
Oh, you had a... You had a gas tear.
Okay, I got it.
I do.
I got it.
I thought you had some too.
I do.
I have three.
I remember you had some as well.
Okay.
Wait.
So now I do the gas tear and then I do the redstone as usual.
Wait, so what was the point of the magma?
Magma cream.
I think there was no point.
I think they were trying to tell us it was useless.
It breathes weird purple pain gas.
That's weird.
Oh, it's for the fortress.
Wait, we don't have... Wait, what?
The glowstone?
Wouldn't it be better if it lasted longer than the glowstone?
Okay, I'm mining.
I'm mining.
Alright.
Alright, I got... I got some.
I'll put some... If I get two more, I can get protection four on both of my fucking items.
Do you know... Do you see any glowstone in there?
Yeah, I can get some.
Okay.
Any glowstone for...
For the potions.
Okay, I'll grab them then.
I wish making potions gave you experience.
You can put some stuff in the furnace.
I have nothing though.
Don't we have like copper?
I thought we had copper.
I thought we had a lot of copper.
Nah, I don't see it.
I think you got rid of all the copper.
Oh, I might have.
I might have thrown them away.
Honestly, I'm not surprised.
Okay, I got the experience.
Cook meat.
Oh, there's a meat.
Thanks guys.
Oh, I have lots of meat.
Right here.
I'm gonna have to grab some more rocks here.
So I can make sure not to accidentally mine the gold.
I'll go grab the glowstone.
Look at how we're making meat.
What's happening?
We're doing the final preparation.
Can I cook the ancient debris in the blast furnace?
You can, I'm pretty sure, right?
It seems like you could.
Oh, I need four.
What am I cooking?
I'm scared.
Will it still work?
Oh wait, it turned into scrap.
I remember it turned into scrap.
Little scrap.
It'll go away.
It's gonna go away.
It's gonna go away, guys.
The gas is gonna go away.
The gas will go away.
The gas is gonna go away, I believe.
I believe.
The blast furnace gives you half XP?
No way.
That's a scam.
I can't believe it.
Oh god.
How did they do 20 days of this?
They were barely alive.
Did you watch all of it?
No, I watched some of it, but they were not alive.
I think by day 7, they weren't even alive anymore.
They weren't even there anymore.
I'm so sad.
I remember at the Kaisen Island speed.
When they did their infamous Minecraft challenge, they were not alive.
They like, okay, you know what's really...
They like streamed their showers and everything too.
Yes!
They like...
They were in their swimming trunks, but they were like...
They basically showered on stream and everything.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
That's horrifying.
I put it in your potion box.
Chest?
Okay, cool.
Trying to find more animals to kill.
I'm hungry for blood.
Alright, I'm going to enchant my boots.
Armadillo, I could never hurt you.
What the hell is this?
What the fuck is this?
I don't have feather falling on it though, so that's unfortunate.
But that's the best I can do.
What is this thing?
I got an armadillo scoot.
Oh, that's to make the armor.
That's to make the armor.
You can make armor for your dog.
Yeah, you were the one that told me that.
I know, but I didn't know what it was when I grabbed it.
I put glow dust in the area.
Also, we're going to have to really stock up on food, so we'll have to...
I have a lot of bread, so...
But meat gives more...
Okay, I have cows or... which one?
Cows, pigs, or lambs?
Any of them.
I'm grabbing some of them.
I can kill some of them right now.
I'm heading over.
Oh yeah, I can go to the quartz mine.
Yeah, you go farm quartz, I'll go get some meat for us.
Okay, I was just trying to make these...
I put glow dust too.
You want to put stuff in the glow dust?
And...
Wait, does water work in the ender?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
You can have a scoot.
You can see how ugly it looks.
Oh no, I'm pretty sure it sounds ugly.
It's really ugly.
It sounds very ugly.
Okay, so now we glowstone it.
Now we glowstone it.
Alright.
Okay, I got us...
eight lamb chops.
I'm going to throw away this meat too.
And then...
Oh yeah, didn't we want to bring snowmen?
No, we don't.
No.
There's no point.
There was a snow point.
Oh my gosh, the regeneration...
So the endermen don't come near us because the endermen don't like the snow.
Yeah, but that's important, right?
I don't think we have snow though.
We need silk touch.
We don't have that.
So this is our one life.
Water works better than snow.
Oh, oh, no.
I have a bucket anyway.
I almost messed it up.
We can just make a water pool in the center.
Should we just bring two buckets?
One would be used as a water pool.
So we bait the endermen, we can just put a pool.
Oh yeah, there is a way to shovel...
Use a shovel to pick up snow, but...
And then we can turn the snowballs into cubes.
But...
If water's fine, we should be fine.
Yeah, let's just use water.
It's just easier.
That should be fine.
Yeah, water bucket is just easier.
Make sure I have... Oh my god, there's so much sheep here.
I'm getting the sheep.
Okay.
Goodbye sheep.
We need you to die so we can live.
This is what my power is worth.
Oh, I forgot the glowstone.
Glow dust.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh, this blaze rod lasted forever.
That's awesome.
Yeah, you can make three potions, I think.
That's what they said.
Yeah, but...
Okay, so one blaze rod turns into two powders...
And I've only used one powder this entire time.
Oh, wait, that's...
That's a lot.
Wowee, we're learning so much about Minecraft from this challenge.
We're learning so much.
Oh my god, didn't you like participate in a competition and win?
How do you not know anything?
The competition has nothing to do with Minecraft.
It's just parkour and minigames.
And I played Valorant...
I somehow was able to play Valorant in Minecraft.
I don't know how, but I played Valorant in Minecraft.
Okay.
Anyway, I have to do that competition again on Monday.
Not Monday, on Saturday.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
She got so offended, you guys.
Oh my god.
How did I get lost?
What?
Tell me.
Give us the coordinates.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, I'm looking at the coordinates right now.
I'm, like, wondering where I went.
I traveled so far.
The sun is setting.
Oh, we put pumpkin heads!
Pumpkin heads!
Pumpkin heads makes Enderman neutral.
So we wear pumpkin heads.
Oh yeah, but we can't see.
Oh, that's true.
That's true, nevermind.
Oh wait, does this count?
You guys, I have nothing left.
I have no dust powder.
No blaze powder left.
But did it work?
Heading back.
I think I'm heading back.
Guys, I'm lost.
Where did I go?
I don't know where I went.
I don't want to use all blaze powder.
You think it's fine just for three potions, guys?
Is this where I went?
How did I go so far?
Are you not able to sleep?
Um...
I'm trying.
Oh my god, am I heading the right way?
Yes, I am.
I'm coming back.
I don't know how I got here.
I'm heading back now.
I'm heading back.
I see the tower.
I know where you are.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
I'm here.
Alright, let's sleep.
I got lots of meat for us.
Hello, boy.
There's a creeper right over the way.
Oh, it's okay.
It's not like he's going to come over here and kill us.
Yeah, I wouldn't do that, coward.
You wouldn't do it.
That's such a lame-ass thing to do.
Oh my god, I have so much lamb.
I'm going to put the meat here and then...
Uh...
I'll put the raw meat here and try to find more meat for us.
Wait, where did my...
Guys, where did my...
Where did my...
Where did the thing underneath go?
What did I press?
What did I...
Oh, F1.
How did I...
Wait, that's not F1.
It's not F1.
What did I...
What?
That's...Why is F1...
Why is F1 that?
I pressed F1.
What are you talking about?
How do I...Oh.
Oh, that's what I did.
No, I couldn't see my thing for a while.
It's going crazy.
I couldn't see my HUD.
I was trying to figure out how to un-HUD it.
Or HUD it back.
HUD it back.
Okay, I got it.
What else do we need, chat?
I'm going into the nether.
Get your quartz.
I'm farming more meat.
Okay.
What else do we need?
Follow my torches.
You'll find lots of quartz there.
Okay.
You got this, man.
That's me.
I'm back here once again.
I'm fucking back here.
We never thought we'd be back, but here we are.
Back in hell.
Alja.
I hate you.
We never thought we'd be back, but here we are.
Okay, I'm following your torches.
Oh, here's some.
Okay.
I'm mining.
I got to level 30.
Nice.
That's all you need.
Wait, when you reset, does mine also reset?
I don't think so, right?
That shouldn't be the case, right, everybody?
Okay.
Like, you're...
Oh, okay, so now I have to...
Alright, we can get...
Reset it here.
No?
Okay, so...
Okay, that's good to know.
Alright, I have a lot of different types of meat for us, too.
A lot of variety.
So I think we should have enough.
We should have enough for the dragon.
It's like KBBQ up in here.
Yeah, we have all different flavors.
All different flavors and tastes and variety.
Exciting!
Exciting.
Alright, here we go.
I'm coming back.
Okay.
I'm coming back with all the meat.
And I'm just gonna start burning them.
I'm gonna start burning them and then...
Oh my god, that's a skelly.
Oh my god, what are you doing here?
Did you get the salt?
Oh god, I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
I'm fine.
I got him.
I killed him.
I killed the ghast.
He was low enough for me to kill him.
Okay, okay, that's good.
I'm still running over.
I'm not gonna die.
Maybe I will die.
Don't say that.
Don't ruin my portal, please.
I want us to die at the end.
If we're gonna die, we have to die...
at least make it to the end of Dragon where we're gonna die.
That's where we're gonna die.
I can't leave.
I'm stuck in here and I have no food.
Yeah, because I can't get through the portal.
Or else he's gonna destroy it.
Don't destroy the portal, please.
I can't run.
I'm heading over.
I don't think you can do anything unless you have...
Okay, I think he...
He's fine now.
Go through it.
I'm here.
Go through the portal.
You're fine.
I'm here.
Did you get through?
No, no, no.
I'm farming.
I'm gonna farm some quartz.
It's okay.
I'm here.
I'll protect.
I'll protect the portal.
I got another gas tier.
Lucky.
That's not a regen.
I can make six more regens.
That's good.
What should we do?
No, I didn't have any bows and arrows.
I just went in.
Raw doggin' it, baby.
Go in.
Yeah.
So many fucking...
piglings.
Oh, I didn't get a thing.
Piglings.
They're everywhere.
Okay.
I'm doing something very...
Oh, I can't do this.
I can't do this.
I can't fucking...
Oh my god, there he is.
There's the...
Nope.
Don't do that.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Are you okay?
Yes, I'm alright.
I'm alright.
I was fucking bobbing and weaving.
Bobbing and weaving.
Did you meet a coven?
No, I'm alright.
I'm alright.
I'm safe.
I made it through.
The gas doesn't know.
Yeah.
The gas is stupid, dumbass.
Yes, it's fucking stupid as hell.
Stupid.
Where's all the books?
I have them here.
And I'll put the lapis on the second chest.
I have lapis.
There's some more.
Okay, um...
Oh god.
I'm just gonna kill wildlife.
Oh, I have infinity!
Wait, that's good!
I need level 30.
Wait, aren't you level 30?
I'm 28.
I used my levels to do another thing.
Oh, okay.
That's not good.
Let me see if you have anything you can...
Wait, if the thing...
Can you get XP from meat?
Cooking meat?
Yeah, you can.
Okay, I put some stuff in there so you can grab the meat for...
What the hell is a bundle?
What do you mean?
I just looked at my things I can create.
And what is a bundle?
I don't know.
Yeah, just get the stove for XP.
I'm gonna make...
Can hold a mix stack?
What?
What is this?
Oh, extra storage?
Yeah!
Break the furnace for XP?
It's full.
Wait, how do I make it empty?
Just pick it up.
I'm gonna see if there's any animals I can kill.
Oh, I can kill the squids.
Yeah, you're right.
Wait, you can kill squids for XP?
Squids and fish...
You can kill anything for XP.
I'm gonna swim out.
I think we got all the quartz too at the...
We got all the quartz that are close.
In the near area, yeah.
I think the others are just way too dangerous for us to farm at that point.
Especially because there's like skellies and gas in that area really badly.
Yeah.
I would advise not to go any further.
I farmed all the ones that were far, but like, not dangerous.
Cook the fish too.
Cook the fish.
Cook any types of meat and stuff.
I cook the fish.
You cook the fish?
I wish I could kill the birds.
I wish I could just kill the birds that are flying up here.
I wish I could just...
I don't see any birds.
No, they exist!
They exist!
They're there!
No, they're not.
There's no birds.
They're real!
They're real to me.
There's no birds.
They're real.
What does that mean?
It's a shared hallucination.
They're real to me.
Yeah.
So is Santa Claus.
Santa Claus is real.
I know.
He's real to me.
He's real to all of us.
Oh, I'd be so sad if I died by drowning.
If that was the way I go.
That would just be really sad, yeah.
I'd be so sad if that was the way I decided to go after everything I've been through.
I decided to just drown and put myself out of my misery.
That's a valiant way to go down, probably.
Go, die!
Die!
Die, squid, die!
I can't stop going so fast.
We have to go back.
It's almost night time.
Okay.
I'm killing the fish.
And then I'm cooking the fish.
I'm gonna kill the cows.
And I'm gonna kill the chicken.
Kill the chicken.
Kill the cow.
I'm gonna kill the koala.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna salad fingers these.
I'm gonna salad fingers.
Oh no.
Sleep, sleep, sleep.
Oh yeah, check the furnace.
I will.
I have been asleep.
Okay.
Did you get enough XP?
No.
I have like nothing.
How much does it give you?
I'm still...
I'm not even halfway through 28.
Do we need all those enchantments?
Do we?
Do we really need everything?
Everybody.
Guys, do we really need...
If we stock up on all the potions...
Remember how I said we gotta farm all the redstone for XP.
I told you man.
I did.
I told you.
I told you as much as we could.
I'm just saying.
I was at level 35.
I told you.
Yeah, we have to have infinity at least on one of our bows though.
Yeah, I have power.
Do you have arrows?
I can give you some of the arrows I made.
If I have infinity, I only need one.
Oh, that's true.
Doesn't it...
Sometimes it runs out.
It's literally called infinity.
Wouldn't it like break?
Wait, really?
You're thinking of like the bow will break.
Oh!
I can give you one of my arrows.
Yeah, we do need anvil though.
To make it...
I made an anvil already.
We have an anvil everybody.
We're set.
Where is more coal that I can mine?
Just killing the wildlife.
Do horses give XP?
Oh, I don't think so.
Do horses...
There's a lot of horses.
I'm thinking about it.
Just kill one and test it for science.
No, because they hit back.
They fight back.
They do?
The other wildlife don't fight back.
They do.
They do give XP.
Yes!
Let me sneeze.
Okay, they do.
They do.
Oh my God.
Do armadillos give XP?
No, don't kill the armadillos.
Do they give XP?
Probably nothing.
He's just a small little guy.
Don't do it.
He's too cute.
They do?
I'm fucking going in.
I'm getting us...
I'm getting us meat for food.
I have so much meat right now.
Oh, there's a pillager right here.
Better not look at him.
Where did I get the pill here?
I'm not going to look at him.
I'm fucking bloodthirsty right now.
I'll kill anything and everything except for the pillager.
Because I don't want to deal with that.
You could kill him and then...
Take his stuff.
No, you get the...
You get the potion now.
Oh, okay.
I'll just go kill him then.
Yeah, kill him.
Who cares about his measly little life?
He's a pathetic man.
Whoa.
Pathetic little pillager guy.
Alright.
I guess I'll go kill him now.
He's a pathetic little guy.
Did he disappear?
Where did he go?
He deserves death.
Yeah, he's afraid of me.
He actually heard you.
He despawned.
He actually despawned.
He's like, He's like, I'm out.
Oh my god.
Never mess with me, little pillager man.
He ran away so fast.
Oh my god.
There's a dripstone in here.
He actually disappeared.
That's my power.
He got scared.
Oh, baby.
Oh, baby man.
You donkeys give...
It doesn't matter, I'm gonna still kill him.
Kill, kill, kill, kill.
Kill all of them.
This was what my power was for.
I'm coming back.
Okay.
I'll go back too.
More meat.
Give me all my meat, please.
Give me all these deaths.
Death to the wildlife.
Might as well go extinct in this world.
Yeah.
If we're gonna go extinct, the wildlife too.
If we're gonna suffer, they all suffer.
They all suffer.
Do my dogs...
Oh my god.
Would you really?
If you were so desperate for XP, would you kill your friend?
Do my dogs give...
Does Doki give XP?
Does he give XP?
Does he?
Your laugh is getting more and more maniacal.
I don't wanna waste a level.
I was gonna name one of them.
Look him in the eye and ask, Do you give XP?
Do you give XP?
That's kinda raw, man.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna check.
The Lulu laugh.
Do you give XP?
Do you?
Okay, um...
I need...
I need to...
You can take the burning and the meat and stuff for the...
I know, I've been taking it.
Yeah, just take it.
You can have it.
I'm still... I'm not even at level 29, though.
Uh...
I know it's painful.
Can you pass me a book?
Oh wait, no, never mind.
I was gonna say, I left half of them in there.
I'm resetting.
I need to reset one.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to bring a lapis.
Wait, you have all the lapis?
Oh no, the lapis is here.
No, there's lots of lapis in there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Time to go to the jungle.
In the jungle...
Blast?
Why does it keep giving me...
I'm just gonna get protection 2.
I'm just...
Guys, I'm just gonna get protection 2.
Like, I...
There's no... There's only blast protection.
Guys, this is it.
This is the best I can do.
I can't...
Protection 2 is fine.
Protection 2...
Don't piss me off.
You look like you...
Are just enough EXP.
Are those real t-shirts?
Someone said that...
This song has gotten more and more sad...
As the time goes on.
Hey...
What are you playing?
No, the...
The Lion Sleeps Tonight.
The more I sing that song...
The sadder it becomes.
I know, I was really excited about it at first.
The lion sleeps tonight...
I wish I were that lion...
Why is there no coal?
No chicken?
There's a lot...
For farming.
There's a lot of coal in the...
What else do you need?
My arm is fully ready.
I still need my helmet and my pants.
And then I was gonna do my...
And then I was gonna get the infinity on the book.
So you could have...
I was gonna let you have it.
No, I don't need it.
You can...
You can have infinity and then...
My bow is already power.
I already have power on my bow.
You can put infinity on it too.
That's fine, I don't need it.
I actually don't need it.
I have enough arrows.
But you'll be using more of the arrows than me, probably.
I have 45.
So it's fine.
I have 45 normal arrows.
And then 20 spectral arrows.
20...
I don't think spectral arrows do more damage.
Yeah, but it's just arrows.
Lucky.
That's fine.
I don't need another infinity.
I think we should just go with whatever...
Try to level up all your stuff.
And then...
Like all your armor, because I'm done, I think.
Sorry, kid.
Sorry, you have no mom anymore.
I'm so sorry.
This is fine.
Guys, believe.
Believe in this.
I don't think they believe in this.
Guys, believe.
I've done this before.
I think I once soloed the ender dragon.
Yeah, I think you did, actually.
I remember.
I feel like I did that.
But I had, like, way better stuff.
That's true.
Didn't you have netherite stuff?
Oh, I also have to... Oh, shit.
I'm gonna...
Oh, God.
I'm not... I'm kind of lost.
Oh, no.
The sun's coming down.
Okay, coordinates are...
I can't look at it yet, because I'm in bed.
Oh, I see it.
Never mind.
I'm coming.
No, Mint.
You got the infinity, right?
You already got it on your own.
No, I haven't put it on yet, but I will...
Yeah.
I'm coming to bed.
I'm almost there.
I lit up the area a little bit, so it should be, like, not so dangerous.
I'm on my way.
I'm sleeping.
I'm eating.
My chat doesn't...
They don't believe.
They're like, yeah, you're cooked, but you might win.
What the hell?
Believe?
This is our one run.
Why?
We have one run.
Why don't you believe?
Why don't you believe in us?
Oh, my God.
We have one run.
You have to believe in us.
Please believe in us.
I have no faith in us.
We need this wood.
Okay, I'm gonna put, like, trash stuff in my inventory that I don't need.
Okay, I need the torch.
I need this.
I don't need the gold helmet anymore.
I'm gonna grab wood just in case.
I don't need...
I'll grab this just in case, too.
And then get the bed.
Get this out of here.
Get the wood rid of this.
We need coal.
We don't need this.
We have this.
This is fine.
We don't need this.
Have you guys found the end portal?
Are we gonna do that the moment we're finished kidding ourselves about?
We're gonna get that into that.
I'm gonna make the end pearl things into the thing.
Okay, I have one, two, three, four, five beds.
That's enough beds.
Eye of Ender.
Oh, you should make that, actually, right?
I'm making the eyes of the ender.
One, two, three, four, five, six, I have seven beds.
I have seven beds.
I don't think... I think you need like a twenty... Isn't it like a ton of beds, you guys?
I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
We have these two beds.
Eight, nine.
We have nine beds.
It's okay.
We'll just do it with our power.
Wait, do you have extra iron or no?
I can make iron ingots.
No, I don't have any.
Okay.
I think I have enough for... Do I have enough for...
Okay, one.
How many for a bucket?
We're already an hour in.
We need three.
Okay, so I need two more.
I need...
Wait.
Oh no.
I don't have enough.
I only have one bucket.
Eye of the ender.
Do you have a bucket on you?
Yeah, I have one bucket.
Okay, we both have a bucket, so it should be fine.
I think we need more.
Don't we need to...
Don't we need to cover the ground with water?
That's our one bucket for.
That's not gonna cover the whole ground.
We don't have enough iron.
We actually don't have enough iron.
Unless I swim.
Time to find iron.
Two by two infinite water.
Will that work?
We need four buckets of water then, right?
We need four buckets of water to make the two by two.
We just need two?
We both have two.
We just need to make sure we don't fuck up the infinite water source.
Alright, let's fucking...
We only have one!
One bucket?
No, we have two!
I mean, we only have one chance for this.
And if we don't succeed, people are gonna see the two vods and be like, oh, of course they made it.
They're not gonna watch this at the end, right?
They're not gonna...
We could just cut it and say that we had streaming issues.
But we didn't.
Take a screenshot on Google.
Yeah, yeah.
We can photoshop our characters in it.
We can hire someone on Fiverr to paint it with our skins.
We've just put in the new video when we made it different.
We managed to record it.
We managed to record the final fight.
And then we upload it as a video and then nobody will know.
How would they know?
So we need iron.
I'm gonna go look for some more coal, too.
I need to just get a little bit more level.
How much more levels do you need?
One, but I'm at 29.
But like...
At the lower end, 29?
Yeah.
Did you grab everything for cooking?
Okay, I'm grabbing this copper then.
So I can cook it for you.
And you just grab the stuff.
Okay.
I'm searching.
Wait, so do you think I shouldn't get infinity then?
Or should I?
No, you should get infinity.
I think infinity is more important.
Okay, I'll get infinity and I'll...
So then I can give you the arrow and then you do the infinity stuff.
Okay.
I'll do infinity.
And I'll just do like a second level for my...
For my helmet and my pants.
And then we can...
We can head off into the...
You know, if we lose this run and we do it again, I will not be surprised if it's easier.
I wouldn't.
I won't?
Yeah, I feel like if...
I feel like...
I feel like we've gotten the bad end of the stick in a lot of these.
I think we just got the worst seed possible.
I think so too.
Maybe we should just die right now and restart with a new seed and it'll be easier.
Maybe we should just do that.
We're gonna die.
At least die at the dragon.
At least die.
At that point, let's just go find the stronghold.
What if we die in the little stronghold?
Let's just find the stronghold at that point.
Like, fuck getting anything else.
Why is there nothing around here?
This area sucks.
Wait, wait, wait.
We bring the enchantment table and the books with us.
To the stronghold.
And then we can get XP at the stronghold.
Oh, true.
Yeah.
Okay, we can do that.
Just grab everything that we're gonna bring to the...
So are we picking up shop or leaving now?
You're packing up shop.
This is it.
This is the final hour.
Wait, don't you need a silk touch to get ready to take out the...
Take out what?
The enchantment table.
Wait, really?
You need silk touch?
Oh, I also might lose...
Wait, if you break the enchantment table, you reset the enchantment?
Yeah, I'll lose infinity.
Okay, let's just make a new enchantment table.
I have enough diamonds.
Alright, saying goodbye to...
Wait, what do we need for enchantment tables?
We need...
We also need the bookshelves.
Three obsidian...
Yeah, bookshelves we can remake easily.
Okay, we just get more book...
I mean, more wood.
Okay.
Oh, it was not five days.
It was much longer than five days.
I remember watching that stream.
I remember it taking much longer.
But yeah, there's a library in the stronghold.
Oh, I can mine it?
People are saying I can break the enchantment table.
You can?
I thought you need a silk touch one.
You can mine it?
But I don't have silk touch.
Oh, I guess you can mine it.
Oh, just maybe people are...
Someone says don't, others say don't.
Some says yes.
Get infinity first before...
Wait, she doesn't have the levels.
They're saying you can mine it.
When you get rid of it, I won't have infinity.
Oh, you don't have your infinity.
Yeah, you're right.
Ah, what do we do?
You need one level, right?
Okay, I'll put stuff in the...
How much more from that one level?
I'm going back into the nether.
No, don't do it.
It's too risky.
How much more do you need?
I need a lot.
You need a lot?
A lot, a lot.
How much is a lot, a lot?
I think I need to go back and I'm going in.
No!
Wait, can you come with and build a wall, right?
So that if a gas spawns by the...
I'll build a house around it.
Yeah, build like an ugly house.
I need stuff.
I'm gonna get dirt.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
You can go in person, because you'll be walking away from it, right?
Okay.
Where did I put the shovel?
Okay, I'm gonna go grab dirt and then build stuff around it.
I think I see some quartz.
Oh, shit.
There's already a gas.
No, there's already a gas.
I'm grabbing dirt.
I'm grabbing dirt as fast as I can.
I can't use the wood, guys.
The wood is for something else I'm trying to make.
The wood is for something else I'm trying to make right now.
Okay.
I'm digging like kind of a hole for me, so that...
Oh, oh, my pickaxe just broke.
Oh, no, I'm coming in.
I'm giving you my pickaxe.
Okay.
You can find me in a hole.
Here, this way.
Do you see me?
Give me a sec, I'm building the house first.
I think maybe he despawned.
I don't hear him anymore.
I don't hear him either.
Can I have your pickaxe?
Yeah, just give me a sec, I'm building my little house.
Yeah, okay.
That works, yeah.
Thank you.
Just for a moment.
Alright, I'm grabbing more dirt.
Okay.
I'm just gonna sleep through this night, too.
Oh, my God, I do hear still the gas.
I hear him.
I know, I'm grabbing more stuff for the house.
I'm mining the dirt.
I ran out of dirt.
Okay, I'm almost halfway.
Where is he?
I'm just gonna get 40 and then go back in.
Oh, I see him over there.
Cobblestones, I can't get cobblestones.
I don't have cobblestone.
I don't have my pickaxe anymore.
And we don't have iron.
Oh, God.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Please despawn.
You ugly.
Okay, he might despawn now.
Oh, my God.
I'm in my little hole.
I'm in my hole.
There was one more quartz area that I think I can get to.
Is he gone?
No, he's not gone.
I don't know.
Just stay in your little hole.
You know what?
I'm just gonna mine.
I'm just gonna strip mine here.
And then maybe I'll hit quartz.
Safely.
Perhaps.
I'm gonna mine some more dirt for us.
Oh, my God.
Please go away.
I just gotta get a few...
I just gotta get a few more...
of experience, guys.
It's just almost there.
Did you get quartz?
Don't burn.
I'm trying not to.
In fact, maybe I can mine it from here.
Oh, thank God.
Alright, I'm going through the portal to see if he's there.
I think he is.
Don't say that.
I'm being as safe as I possibly can.
Oh!
So close to 30.
So close.
Oh, my God.
I'm so close to level 30.
There you go.
I feel a little bit more safe now.
Oh, more quartz.
Okay.
There we go.
We're a little safer now.
I made a little hut.
I got to level 30.
I can do infinity now.
Yeah!
I'm going to put torches for you so you know this is where we live.
Okay.
I think I know, but...
Alright, here we go.
There's all the torches.
There's all the torches in the world.
I wish I was farming quartz.
I'd be rich in quartz.
I wish we...
Alright, is the gas still there?
I wish we died earlier.
I don't know.
I wish we...
I wish we didn't stayed in this seed.
I know, me too.
I wish we died in the nether.
In the very beginning of the nether.
Me too!
No, not in the very beginning of the nether!
It would be so long from now.
Okay, I'm back.
Oh, where is it?
Where are you?
You know what I also wish?
Here's your pickaxe.
I wish we got out of the mines earlier.
I wish we got...
Do you regret what you did in the mines?
Here, take your pickaxe.
I regret this entire event.
I regret everything.
Wait, why can't I do infinity?
Oh, three lapis.
Oh, that's why.
Okay.
Okay, I got infinity.
I put it on my block.
It's already time to break.
I'll break it now.
I'm breaking it.
Okay.
I got the enchanting table.
And then I'm gonna grab the bookcases too.
Bing bong bing.
Okay.
Name it?
No!
My levels are precious!
I'm not gonna waste a single level on a name.
His name is Bow.
I'm gonna remake the bookshelf.
I think...
I really think, Doki, this bow would be better with you, since it's a powerful bow.
Mine has power 4.
And mine has unbreaking 3 also.
Only unbreaking 3?
What's yours unbreaking?
Mine has power 4.
Mine has power 4, unbreaking 3, and infinity.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
One and done?
Oh my god.
This is embarrassing.
I don't want this thing.
What the hell?
Why is it embarrassing?
Here's your fucking arrows.
Oh, thank you.
You have arrows?
You have one arrow?
Yeah, I have one arrow.
Do you want spectral arrows too?
No, no, it's okay.
Why is it...
No, we can't combine the bows, guys!
Because Mint needs the bows too.
Yeah!
She needs the bows as well.
I need the bows.
It's telling us to combine the bow with the mintues.
They're trying to sabotage us.
Alright.
Did you make the eye of ender?
Yeah.
Don't do the bed strap because it's not good and only for speedrunners.
Look, I've done the bed strap before.
You have?
Yeah, we've done it together during that run we had.
I didn't do it.
No, I didn't do it.
Didn't we do it?
I thought I did.
I don't think so.
Pretty sure.
It could kill us.
Yeah, that's what I'm feeling.
Okay, I'll get rid of the beds.
Fine.
I'll get rid of them.
I don't have any...
You guys, I gave away my infinity bow.
That's why I have all the arrows.
I gave...
Oh, man.
I think some people are more tired than me.
Alright, I'm gonna...
Alright, let me...
I'm just making...
Okay, bookshelf.
I'm just remaking the shelves for us.
We're not enough wood?
Do you have wood or no?
Not a lot of wood, no.
Okay, I'll just farm the last trees here.
Yeah.
And then we'll head over.
We'll head over.
Please, it's 440.
It's 540 for me.
Okay.
The sun's almost up, guys.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Wood.
I can't do much more.
That's why we have the last rug.
Me too.
I thought we'd be at the dragon by now.
I don't know why we're still here.
Okay, then let's go.
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize how under-leveled we were.
I thought we leveled up so much.
I told you.
You had the same amount of wood.
I know, but I told you we needed so so many.
There were so many cords that we didn't pick up.
We were so stuck.
They were so long.
What?
Don't forget the potions.
Why didn't the chat tell us to pick up the cords?
Yeah, why didn't the chat tell us to pick up the cords?
You guys should have been saying, Hey, you can need more levels.
Get the cords.
Yeah, get more of the cords.
Get more of the cords.
Get more of them.
You should have said, Give more of the cords, chat.
If you said, give more of the cords, I would have got more of the cords.
We would have been like, oh yeah, that's a good plan.
We need the cords for the...
We need the cords for that.
Why didn't you get those?
I didn't know.
Chat, why didn't you tell us about the cords?
Do you think my sword will last, you guys?
Just...
Okay, what potions do I get?
Potion regeneration.
You made so many.
Yeah.
You don't get all of them.
Half and half.
That's not half, but okay.
I got two for five for regen, and then two for four for slow falling.
Yeah, that's half.
It's literally half.
What the fuck are you talking about?
You have five for both, and I have four.
I have two for five for regen, and then two for four for slow falling.
Okay, so you're giving me slow... Okay, I get it.
Should we just...
Should I make more?
I can...
No, I think we're fine.
It's not gonna take us that long.
It's four minutes each.
We're not gonna take 30 minutes to kill this dragon.
We either die within 10 minutes, or we do something in 10 minutes.
It's one or the other.
We die in 10 minutes.
Okay, we gotta sleep in the bed before we fucking leave.
Another rock?
He'll blow it up, right?
What?
Someone just said...
This message got delayed.
Pick up the quartz.
What?
We would've been like level 70.
We would've been so good.
I'm gonna grab netherrack for like when we...
When we need to climb.
Did you grab the enderpearl and eye of ender stuff?
Yeah, I have all that.
I'm gonna grab your potions.
Yeah, I know.
I'm making space.
I'm gonna bring the brewing stand just in case.
Oh, pickaxe?
Yeah, I need that.
You have a lot of wood, right?
I have 14.
We can grab some while we're fucking heading over to the stronghold wherever it is.
We're just gonna be so many trees.
Okay, I'll get rid of that.
Hold on, guys.
Sorry.
I'm putting stuff away.
I'm making stuff.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
I'll take my sticks.
Grab blocks while we're on the way, chat.
There's so many blocks ahead of us.
We can grab blocks while we're going there.
There we go.
I got water.
You got all the food?
We gotta get the food.
I got...
44.
I think you have the...
Chicken, right?
I got the beefs and the chickens, yeah.
I had pork chop and mutton.
So we can split that.
You take those.
I take the others.
Take the beds.
There's so much we can do to prepare.
There's so little time left in our bodies.
Yeah.
Our bodies are gonna expire soon.
We don't have...
We don't have the time to prep more.
I'm taking the melons until the fight.
I want the melons to just keep...
Two different types of tiredness from Min and I.
Min is the...
I'm gonna fucking pass out.
I am hysterical and I'm delusional right now.
I'm a type of tired.
I'm delulu at the moment.
Delulu.
Two types of tiredness from us.
Yeah, we don't need the NHS.
We don't need it.
They're telling us we need an ender chest?
It's for more room, but we don't.
We don't need it.
No, we're fine.
We do need it.
Well, I have one other shield.
Okay, I actually have two shields.
Maybe I'll be okay.
Wait, can I put something in my little bundle?
Can I put...
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, I can put the food in the bundle.
Oh, that's smart.
Oh, it's full.
This thing sucks.
Maybe we should have made an ender chest.
Do we have enough ender pearls for an ender chest though?
That's the thing.
No, we need to save all eyes of ender.
We need to save all of them.
Yeah, okay.
I'm ready.
I'm missing one slow falling pot...
You know what?
Fine, go waste it.
Okay.
Actually, I'm gonna make...
Wait, even if I make a pickaxe, I can't take it.
We need these pearls, you guys.
We need these for...
We need them.
We'll make the chest with...
I mean, it wouldn't matter by then.
The bundle for the pearls.
How do I take stuff out?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, hold on.
Oh no, only one.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Whippy!
No, I'm taking the...
You guys, we're making the...
We're remaking the enchantment table so when we get there...
Yeah, yeah, I have everything.
I have the enchantment table and I have 15 bookshelves.
And I have lapis lazuli.
Actually, well, get books there.
No...
Oh, that's true.
I already made 15.
It's fine.
It's in my pocket.
I feel like we just find...
Straight up find the fucking thing and then...
Put the pearls in there and then...
We call it and then we go in there.
We either kill the dragon or we die.
And then we try this again in another game.
Why do people keep saying the pearls?
I'm so confused.
I have all the pearls.
This is all the pearls.
How many more pearls do we need?
Oh, wait, there's so many more in here.
I didn't even notice them.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, the ones that I gave?
Yeah, those are the ones I put down there.
Oh, I didn't even see.
Okay, hold on.
I need to make way more things.
Hold on.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even see these.
I put them in the beginning.
I told you.
I didn't see them.
That's alright.
We've lost our minds.
Yeah.
We've spent enough.
We've spent enough, guys.
Oh, I didn't know there was more.
If we don't make it this run...
We'll try again another time.
I'm not gonna bring the brewing.
We'll do the stream in the morning instead.
No.
No, I'm not touching my...
No, I'm not meant tomorrow.
I meant like another time.
We'll start it in the morning.
In the future.
We'll try again.
We'll try again in the future.
In the future.
Alright.
I need to make a pickaxe now.
Oh, I can't.
I'm gonna make a diamond one.
You have enough?
Yeah, I think so.
Where did my sticks go?
I have my sticks.
No, guys.
We're not gonna do it in Atlanta, guys.
We have other things to do.
They're like, Hey, how about you do a whole concert and then also stream for 24 hours?
Wouldn't that be super cool?
Yeah, it'll be so fun.
Oh, my God.
I have like experience now with this.
It won't be that bad.
Oh, my God.
That's the funniest thing ever.
We learned so much from this one playthrough.
Are you not bringing the beds?
No, they keep telling us that we're gonna die.
Then it's fine.
We don't need the beds.
Do you think we might need a bed to head over there?
Yeah, bring a bed to sleep.
Alright, I'm throwing away my one iron.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Throw it up into the air and say I don't care.
I don't care.
I'm going up in the air.
I'm going up high.
Throw it in the air and tell the world that you don't care.
Are you gonna say bye to your dads or whatever?
What?
Your dogs.
Oh shit, my dogs.
Get over here.
I almost forgot you guys existed.
I fucking thought you guys died because I was XP crazy.
Catch it.
Wait.
Do I just throw it or do I...
How do I do this?
Sometimes it doesn't break.
Do I just throw it in the air?
Throw it in the air and tell the world you don't care.
Oh, this way.
Oh, it didn't break.
Grab it.
I don't have space.
You gotta grab it.
Okay, I'll grab it.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's go, I guess.
I roll to here and then you throw it in the air.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Goodbye, PP Tower.
Goodbye.
Do you really need to be up top while you throw it?
Can you just throw it here?
No, it's better to throw it up in a high place.
Throw it in the air.
And tell the world you don't care.
Where are you?
I'm here.
Let's just go longer.
Alright, we'll go longer after this.
No!
Oh, it's this way.
Thank God I didn't go longer.
Oh, it's in the tree.
Goddammit.
Is it this way?
Right here?
Yeah, it's like a diagonal.
It's like this way.
That's a new dog.
I told you there were dogs over here.
Come on, come on.
Don't get distracted.
We're going.
I'm going.
I'm heading over.
We're going.
They actually passed over the stronghold on the way back from the long nether trip?
How would we know that?
How do you know that?
Why did no one said anything?
Why did no one super aka super us and be like, That's the stronghold!
Hey, there's the stronghold right there!
Seed checker?
They don't know the seed?
Hey, where are you?
Where are you?
I'm walking in the...
Come on, he like haven't even...
He haven't even made it to...
I'm making a tower.
We went back towards home!
We already went and said goodbye.
It's so awkward.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Give me your coordinates.
Apparently while I had my coordinates...
Because of the biome.
They saw the biome!
Why did you guys not say anything?
Negative 4211899.
421...
Just sleep, just sleep.
Just sleep.
You didn't ask!
Oh my god, this is the most Metal Gear ass.
Thank you.
Thank you, Plissken.
Snake Plissken.
Wait, what's your number again?
4219...
1897.
This is where I fucked up.
Don't say what a thrill, that's the wrong game!
Oh, I see you, I see you.
Really?
Okay.
Keep going straight, keep going straight.
Alright, I'm here now.
Did you see me?
I went the wrong way.
I thought I saw the right way, but I didn't see the right way.
Watch out for the hole.
I'm watching out for the hole now.
I'm eating my bread.
Wait, so then chat...
For people who noticed and just decided not to say anything.
Yeah.
How far away was it?
This is far.
At what point...
Was it there?
We traveled 10,000 plus.
I'm already hungry.
I have lots of bread.
I left my watermelons.
Oh no, my watermelons are in the bundle.
Wait, hold on.
How do I get the watermelons out?
I'm trying to eat the watermelon, hold on.
Okay.
After you're done with the watermelon, I have bread.
Which might be more...
Someone just said no help.
This is ridiculous.
We've been streaming for...
We've been through so much.
At this point, don't you feel anything for us?
Don't you feel like...
Compassion at that point?
Or any sense of...
Human decency?
I can't believe...
Okay, what should I do?
Should I throw one here?
No help.
It's the most...
It's the thing...
It's the one thing I've always wanted to ban from my chat.
It's the fucking no help.
It makes me want to pull out my hair.
Do you want me to become bald?
I will become bald.
They'll enjoy it.
No, don't encourage it.
They'll just enjoy it so much.
I'm bald now.
I never said no, don't backseat.
I am one of the few VTubers out there...
That embraces backseating.
That I was not progressive.
I don't get backseated.
You can't say that about me.
I am all about backseating.
Backseating.
That's some real hope core right there.
That's a good helper.
Santa's little helper.
Thank you, little helper.
Thank you, David.
Did you throw the eye?
Yeah, it's the same direction.
We just gotta keep going.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Help.
I'll wait for you.
I'm right behind you.
I do have to pee though.
Help.
Do you know when we should do the eye?
Do you have blocks?
Oh my god, your dogs are pushing me.
Or you're pushing me.
I'm behind.
Yep, blocks.
I didn't bring blocks.
What do you...
I'll just use some dirt.
Oh wait, I don't have any room.
Okay, I'll use my 7 rock.
Okay.
You can just re-mine it after.
Sure.
They'll fall.
I don't care.
Then what's the point of me re-mining it?
They have no names.
No, I'm not talking about the dogs will fall.
I'm talking about the blocks will fall.
Get the blocks!
I can't!
Do you have a bow?
Yeah.
Yes, help.
Yes.
Wait, I didn't mean to...
Okay, well, get off the boat and I can get on it.
And then you can throw the eye of Ender out there.
And then the world will be a beautiful place.
What if I just kept going?
Alright.
Did it stop?
Just keep going.
What if I just keep going?
Alright, I think we can go to that area and then throw the eye, right?
Would that be fine?
Or should we just keep going?
I don't know how many we have to do before we throw the eye in the air.
I don't know either.
You've done this before.
You've done this so many times.
I've done this two times.
That's two more than me!
That's...
Give me some...
Give me a little bit of a credit.
That's only two times.
That's two more than me.
That doesn't matter.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, are you ready to throw it up?
In the water?
Just throw it up.
Go to the left.
To our left.
I'm going to the left.
To the left.
All my brain cells in a box to the left.
Can I go back now, y'all?
Yeah.
This is not...
My dog came over.
I'm sorry.
I know.
Why are you still here?
Where is he?
Underneath my...
Oh my gosh, no.
Why did you do that?
Under my desk right now.
Oh, your actual dog.
Yeah, my actual.
Okay.
Where does the eye of ender tell you?
Where is your Minecraft dogs?
Where are they?
I don't...it's fine.
It's fine.
Eye of ender.
Tell us where you are.
That way.
Oh, it hasn't broken.
Nice.
Has this been the same one?
Yeah.
The entire time?
Wait, where'd it go?
Where'd it go?
Why don't these things fucking flow, man?
I see it.
It's on me.
I got it.
Okay.
It's fine.
I got it.
This way, right?
Am I going the right way?
I already forgot.
Yeah, you're going the right way.
I can't tell if you're joking or not.
I can't.
No, I actually don't know.
No, I'm talking about someone in chat.
Okay, I'm throwing the eye out to you.
Right here.
Oh, I'm still in the boat.
Yeah, I'm breaking the boat.
Oh, I got it.
Up we go.
Guys, you should buy the concert tickets, guys.
It's the same fun experience.
What if we did this at the concert?
What if we did this, guys?
If you buy our tickets, we'll do this at the concert.
We're just gonna watch us play Minecraft.
You can watch us play Minecraft in 3D.
And watch us lose our minds in 3D.
Buy the tickets and watch us play.
Watch us play in 3D.
Where'd you go?
If only if the concert sells out.
I don't know.
I'm over here.
Oh, I see you.
Only if the tickets sold out, then we'll do it.
It'll be the longest concert ever.
We'll get a world record.
If the venue kicks us out, we're gonna take us to another venue.
And we're gonna keep doing it.
We'll just keep going and going and going.
Everybody!
Only if the concert sells out, though.
We won't do it.
Every single ticket's gotta be gone.
Every ticket has to be gone if you want us to play Minecraft in 3D.
For 24 hours straight.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that.
It's not gonna be when we do the challenge.
We're gonna do the challenge all over again.
Do you really think this is gonna take us 24 hours?
Do you really?
Where did you go?
Oh, I'm right here.
Should we throw it?
Yeah, I'll throw it at the edge of this.
We'll hold you to that.
Alright, fucking buy everything.
Oh my god, that scared me.
That's fine.
I have lots of...
Oh my god.
I need to get dirt.
I need to make sure I stop falling.
Okay, my 7 dirts.
Alright.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Ayavender, guide us!
Ayavender!
We passed it!
Wait, that means it's close!
Oh my god, I'm waking up.
We go to that land, and then we throw the eye again.
We didn't walk that far.
We didn't walk that far this time.
Where'd you go?
Okay, I see you.
Okay, then we throw it here.
Because I know we didn't walk that far compared to the other one.
Oh my god, oh my god, everybody.
Oh my god.
This hopium.
This hopium is right here.
Get the guests on it too.
Everybody gets to play.
Where are you?
Alright, let's maybe sleep first.
And then it'll be a morning surprise.
Hopium.
Good morning.
Surprise.
Come on.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Alright, throw it.
Throw it in the sky.
I'm gonna get the coal real quick.
I'm obsessed with mining coal.
Check.
It says beach.
Don't we have to be in the...
Don't we...
I don't know.
Have to be below...
They said we passed it by...
We passed two strongholds because of our coordinates.
I don't know what to believe anymore.
Well, that's fine.
Of course, maybe we're gonna pass something.
Alright.
Throw!
Over there.
Is it in the water?
Looking at my biome.
Oh.
Wait.
Back here?
Try on top of the hilltop?
Right in here?
Like here?
Hold on, I'm trying...
Try...
On the mountain.
On the mountain?
All the way there?
No.
Because over here, it brought us back this way.
No, because we were all the way down...
We walked further.
No, I threw it right there.
In the...
Should we throw it one more time?
I'm gonna try here.
Huh?
Is it right below us?
Is it in the water?
Okay, I'm gonna go to the other side.
Right here on this hilltop and try now.
Okay.
Please, God, no.
Please be kind to us.
We've been through so much.
We've been through a lot.
Okay, throw.
Oh, no!
It's down there.
Oh, no, it didn't break.
Wow, this thing is indestructible.
It's awesome.
This is the worst seed.
This is the worst seed ever.
This is actually...
This is actually the worst seed ever.
The worst seed we've ever had.
We can probably dig a...
Get doors.
I'm gonna make a door.
We can probably dig...
Like a...
What's it called?
A staircase from the land.
And it should be okay, maybe.
Okay.
I got a door.
Like, what if we dig down from here and then just go over.
Here, right?
It was here, right?
About, yeah, I think.
There we go.
I'm ready to dig down.
Where did you go?
Oh, okay.
Alright, dig down.
I'm ready.
I'll wait for you.
Where's my pickaxe?
I gave it back to you.
I know.
Where did my door go?
Okay, there we go.
Just know the water is gonna go inside, so you gotta keep digging.
You gotta keep digging.
I fucked up my door.
I fucked it up!
What do you mean you...
What did you do?
I died.
Okay.
Alright, come down.
Okay, I'm coming.
Alright.
I don't know how to do this.
Just do a staircase down.
Like a spiral staircase down, I think.
What are we at?
40?
Alright, here we go.
Where's my pickaxe?
Alright.
Oopsie, I just...
Oh, my bad.
That's fine, watch this.
There we go.
Okay, perfect.
Oh, I fucked it up too.
Hold on.
You have the other door?
I have the other door.
Wait, shoot, that's not how that works.
Oh, shoot.
Put it down here.
Give me the door.
Okay, hold on, I'm getting it.
I gotta get it with my hands.
Oh, here, I am here.
Alright, pass me the door.
I gave it to you.
Alright.
Wait, I hear it.
You hear what?
No, that's my music.
Here we go.
I don't know how this works.
How do we do this?
How do we dig?
Are we doing it correctly?
Is this the stronghold area?
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm...
Am I heading correctly to the stronghold?
Am I...
I've never done the stronghold before.
I'm just digging.
I've never...
I've never done stronghold before.
Am I...
Just dig down?
Yeah, just do what you're doing.
Just a little spiral staircase kind of thing.
Just keep going.
Just keep going down, I guess.
Yeah, just keep going.
Keep going down.
We'll get there eventually.
What if we go past it?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I don't think we will.
I need iron.
Do we need iron?
I'll grab some just in case.
Okay.
You'll know when you get to it, though.
Did we miss it?
What if we missed it?
It could...
They're usually pretty deep, right?
It's a cave.
We're at a cave.
Oh, but it's water.
Yeah, this isn't...
What is it?
This is not it.
I'm exploring a little.
Oh, gosh.
Making another spiral staircase?
Come back, come back, come back.
I'm trying to find...
I'm trying to find you, I'm trying to find you.
We're gonna make the other...
Nope, that's just water.
That's just water.
Maybe we should go make some more doors.
That was so close.
That's still water!
Can you set down a...
cooking table?
Yeah.
I can.
I'll make some more doors.
Why is there more water under the water?
Wait, where are you?
Oh, you're over here.
Okay.
Why is there so much water?
Wait, how many?
Why is there so much?
I don't understand.
Why is it just water?
Why is this the worst seat out there?
I...
I don't understand.
Is there anything that's not just water?
Like...
It's water!
Oh my god!
It's a cave within water!
Is that it?
What did you see?
I don't know what I just saw.
You would know if you saw it.
It's like a different block.
There's a different block right there!
No...
That's not it.
That's a normal block.
Oh my god.
I hear a zombie.
Oh, shit.
How is it more submerged in water?
It
could be...
It could be a zombie.
Oh, hi.
It could be a...
It could be a zombie that's in the stronghold.
Maybe?
This is the worst fortress ever.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna start building there.
Okay, and then...
There you go.
I'm in the Minecraft river.
I closed it off a little bit for you.
Throw a pearl?
Would it work if I...
There's more water!
Oh my god.
But there has to be an area.
Use an eye to redirect.
What was that eerie noise?
That's just usually when there's a cave around.
Okay, I'm gonna throw an eye.
Come here, Doki.
I'm gonna do it right here.
Hold on.
I'm gonna do it here.
Okay, so we have some space.
Alright.
Eye!
Go!
What the fuck?
Where did it go?
Where did your fucking eye go?
I don't know.
It's the other way.
Where did it go?
Oh!
It went this way!
It went right over here!
We gotta go this way instead.
Okay, because we grabbed the crafting table.
Oh, did you grab the crafting table?
Yeah, I got it.
Which way did it go?
It went this way.
Okay, I'm gonna mine this way then.
Oh, where are you mining at?
I'm mining this way.
Oh, yeah.
That's good.
Okay, nice.
There we go.
Yeah, this pearl is awesome.
Wait, is this the same?
No, it's not.
It's the same pearl.
Yes, it is.
I saw it broke last time.
No, it didn't.
I've had 21 this entire time.
Oh.
Do I go down?
Oh, are you going forward?
I don't know.
I'm just digging straight.
Should we do another eye?
Yeah, we can do another one.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
Because the eye went kind of upward, so...
Alright, here I go.
Down!
Down?
Where did it go?
I don't know.
Where did your eye go?
I didn't even see your eye.
I don't know.
Did it break?
We should make more space.
It's down though.
It's down for sure.
Oh, gosh.
Alright, I made a spiral down.
Okay.
Did you make a spiral down?
Okay, yeah, yeah, from where that was.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just keep going down.
Don't make it too big of a spiral.
Try to keep it tight.
Okay.
But it's pretty big.
We're in the savanna now.
We're in the savanna.
Now we're in water.
There's water right here.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
We have to go down.
There's literally water.
What do you want from me?
It's water.
This stronghold sucks.
This seed sucks.
Everything sucks.
Everything about this...
I knew this seed was going to be an issue.
I knew this seed was going to be the biggest problem in the fucking world.
I think the first one was the best seed we've had.
Okay, so...
There's a giant cave.
Should we put the...
There's a giant cave here.
And I'm worried.
I don't like that.
Where's giant cave?
Oh gosh.
Over there.
You think it's under there?
You think it's in there?
Well, you got your bucket.
I got my boat too.
You wanna just get a boat and go down or get water?
We'll die.
Get the water.
I'm gonna throw an eye right now.
Can you see with the eye?
We should make more room for this eye.
Okay, let's make some room.
Is this enough room, guys?
We have a lot, yeah.
So I think it's okay.
Alright, here we go.
But it was like over here that it went down.
So it might just go down.
Like, if it goes...
Oh gosh.
Okay, here we go.
Where did your eye go?
It didn't break.
I don't...
No!
It didn't break.
What?
It's down?
It's just that way.
Oh, they always go up.
No, they don't.
One before went down, did it not?
Oh, it doesn't go down.
The fortress is always above Y0?
Huh?
We are above Y0.
We are.
Where did it go?
I don't know.
Is this where we came from?
Are we going the right way?
I don't know where the eye went.
Which direction was the eye?
I did it from here and it went this way.
I'm so confused.
Oh, it can go below.
That person is fucking lying.
I'm gonna remember your name.
I'm gonna fucking remember your name now.
We've been through so much.
What's your fucking name?
I need a...
I'm gonna...
Yeah, okay.
That seems like a name that would lie to me.
The thing is...
The problem is that I'm scared now because we can't find the eyes.
I don't wanna...
Yeah, I don't wanna keep using them and then wasting them.
Yeah.
How many do we need to open the portal?
It's 12, I think, right?
How many do we have now?
19.
I don't remember where it went.
My thing is...
I'm gonna make another...
I need to make another pickaxe soon because mine's about to break.
Uh-oh.
Mine's good, but...
Don't use your pickaxe for...
Just use your fist for this.
It's too late.
This is the worst fucking scene.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna start doing a...
A spiral staircase.
From here.
Sorry, there's no going back.
Alright, alright.
Wait.
Oh, this is the giant cave?
Hold on, I'm looking.
Oh, diamond.
Okay.
Just ignore it for now.
What if it is in this cave?
Usually it's, like, not in a cave cave, right?
What if it is?
What if everything we know...
is wrong?
They said throw it in the cave because there's a big space.
I don't like that idea.
I don't know what else to do.
I think it's more over this way, though.
We're at Y level negative three.
Yeah, but they said...
There's water.
Oh my god.
That scared me.
I got pushed out.
Oh god.
Get the door.
Oh, there's...
Oh, that's not a drown, nevermind.
Oh my god.
Get your...
I don't have the doors, so...
You don't have doors?
I'll go to you, I'll go to you.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, it's fine.
Okay, so...
Here, I have some doors, so take them.
I don't have space.
Oh, throw away some cobblestone or something.
Oh, here comes a drown.
Oh, shit!
No, no, no!
I'm back in the area.
Oh my god, I can't come back.
Where is it?
Where is here?
I can't get to you.
I don't know where!
I'm here!
Look at me!
Hold on, hold on!
Where is my shield?
I don't know where you are!
I'm literally in front of the door.
I'm in front of the door.
Did you eat?
I can't see anything.
I'm in front of the door.
Oh god, I can't see anything.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
This is it!
No, no, no!
Get over here!
Where is down?
I see you!
Follow me!
Why did you open the door?
I didn't open the door!
I was trying to get my shield up.
And then...
I couldn't see anything.
I couldn't see...
I literally could not see anything.
Where did you die?
I just want to know where the stronghold is.
Okay, here, I'll spectate.
No!
I can't spectate!
You can!
I can, but I'm back at our spawn point.
Wait, can I teleport to you?
Where's your eye?
TP...
I just want to know where this is.
Oh my god!
I can't believe!
Everything!
I'm trying to find your eyes!
Press 1?
Oh, wait, so I have to...
How do I do that?
Wait, what's 1 do?
Oh, teleport to player.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm by you.
Okay, hold on.
I can't see anything, man.
I'm looking for the stronghold.
I'm looking for the... I'm in the giant cave!
I'm looking for the stronghold!
Stronghold!
I just want to know where the stronghold is.
That's all I want.
That's actually all I want.
Where are you?
Hold on.
I see it!
I just...
I just want to know where it is.
I don't want much.
I just want to know.
I can't freaking throw away the bed.
I don't need it.
Where is your eyes?
Um...
We were so close to it.
We were...
Like...
Hold on.
Is this a...
Wait, hold on.
No, this wouldn't have made it, but...
Right over...
A little...
Oh my god!
Are you kidding me?
Oh my god.
I don't know if we would have survived.
Honestly though.
Because right inside the stronghold is the trials.
What?
We would have died from these things in here.
This is an absolute...
No, this is a cursed seed.
This seed is absolutely cursed.
No.
No, no, no, no.
Really?
It was next to...
Am I close?
Where are you?
Where is it?
Hold on.
Let me teleport to you again.
Where is it?
We had trials.
We would have had to go through trials to just get to...
That would have been funny though if we actually had to do that.
This was the trial.
How many trials did this...
What did we have to go through?
That would have been funny though.
That would have been really funny if that was how we died instead of the fucking underground.
No, instead I died to a fucking drown because I just can't.
I hate the dumbest fucking enemy in the game.
I hate this.
Tell me where it is.
I want to see a stronghold.
Okay.
Okay, you're kind of far actually.
So you have to...
It's like you're close but far.
It's a bit of a trek to get there.
Okay, how?
Which way?
Okay, hold on.
Where are you?
Let me see.
I have to find you again.
Hold on.
How was there...
How could a trial be next to the merge with my stronghold?
I don't know.
Okay, hold on.
I'm trying to figure out...
I'm doing... I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do spectate.
I'm not... I'm gonna...
Are you gonna die?
No, I'm not.
I was like, how are you gonna spectate?
Where did that drown come from?
He came out of nowhere and then we haven't had a drown with a pickaxe or whatever.
A trident the entire time.
And then...
Then it happened.
And then it just happened.
What...
How am I supposed to do...
And I couldn't... I already...
The foreshadowing...
What was it, guys?
How do I...
Slash game mode...
Spectator?
Oh my god.
I need... I'm giving myself admin.
Give me a sec.
How do I...
How do I admin myself?
How do I mod myself?
Guys, how do I mod myself right now?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna mod myself.
Slash op...
Unknown.
I'm gonna mod myself in the command.
How do I do it?
I can't.
It says unknown or incomplete.
Okay, maybe...
Okay, so basically the way where you're facing from... Like, facing towards the door, you would have to go through the water.
Oh my gosh, this is absolutely cursed.
You would have to dig through the water at the very end, get past a bunch of creepers and zombies, and then dig down...
Where the fuck is this Stockholm?
Where are you?
Where is it?
Are you in...
Yes, where is it?
Okay, come here.
So you would have to go through here...
You would have to go through here and then go down... Look at this.
This is...
This is the Stockholm, but then over here...
If we... Oh my god.
If we had gone any... Oh my god.
The trials are huge.
Is that the trial right there?
Yes!
Is the copper ship the trial?
Oh my god!
What kind of hellhole scene is this?
The portal has no eyes in it?
Would we even be able to fill it up?
Oh my god!
Where's the...
Where's the portal?
Look at this!
We'd just be exploring and then fucking run into the trials!
There's this insanity!
And then there's...
There's a spawner!
Oh my god!
Okay, we had enough.
Oh wow!
This is the worst scene ever!
There's another spawner right here!
This... We...
We fought against this scene every second!
We fought!
Fought!
It's rigged from the start!
Oh my god!
Look!
Look at this!
The trials!
Literally we walk up this door and we'd be in the trials and I'm so absolutely cursed!
Have the seed!
Where are you?
We would just be exploring and we would come upon the trials and then these guys would be released and we would just be dead!
We would just be doing the trials!
And actually we wouldn't even make it to the fucking...
We wouldn't even make it!
With our luck we would not have made it to the fucking... We had to dig underwater!
We had to dig underwater!
And they made the trials harder too!
And hardcore!
It was... Oh my god!
No!
If we dig... Oh my god!
If we had to dig... We just had to dig in the mountain but it showed us not the mountain!
It showed us not the mountain!
If we dig... Oh my god!
If we dig from the underwater that we did, we would have been in the trials.
If we went...
If we followed the water...
If we dug in the water...
It would have been... We would have done to the... We would have dropped into the trial room.
We would have actually...
Oh my god!
You're right!
From down below!
From the water!
Dropped in the trial room!
It's literally the water area!
Oh my god!
If we dug underwater and it told us to dig underwater...
We would have landed in the trials!
It was the...
It was the worst part!
We would have landed in the trials!
You should go back into normal in the trials and see what happens.
See what the trials are like.
Alright, I'm gonna go in.
Because it's these little... What is this?
How do I get into the crate?
Oh, what is this?
Wait, where are you?
It was right...
This is the seed.
Okay, I meant...
Here's the seed, by the way, so you can post it in your own.
This woke me up.
This actually woke me up.
There's a poison skelly spawner?
Okay, wait, where are you?
Where are you?
I'm next to you.
Okay, I'm gonna put in...
I'm gonna put in survival.
Okay, good luck.
Here I am.
How does it work?
Here comes Ace.
Oh my god.
There's like poison skellies here.
How do I start the trials?
I think you just exist in here and the trials start.
Oh, here's the things.
Oh, there you go.
Here's the breeze.
This is what we had to go through if we lived this long.
If we lived this long.
It's coming for me.
Oh my god, the poison skellies.
This is absolutely cursed.
Oh my god.
This is what I had to go through.
She's doing it, chat.
She's doing it.
Oh my god, my entire chat is just sound effects.
I know, I see.
It's just...
Oh my god.
That's a spawner so they just don't stop.
They just don't stop.
I can't even destroy this.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
How are you alive?
I'm not okay.
Oh my god.
He's coming inside.
Oh my god, he just destroyed the doors.
You're in the struggle.
It's the only way to get out.
They can open doors.
I know, I know.
Oh my god.
Oh, you killed him, nice.
Oh my god, you're full of arrows.
I made it to the stronghold.
Let's go.
Here's the coordinates, guys.
Here it is.
Oh my god.
I'm glad we ended up committing to see this bullshit.
I can go again.
It opens right up into it.
It opens right...
Oh my god.
This is the worst ever.
There's no way.
I think if we had lived here, I just would have turned around and been like, go straight to the eye.
Do not...
Don't look at anything else.
Don't even...
We can't even find the eye.
We don't even know where the eye was.
There's some spawners up here.
Oh yeah, what's in the chest?
Wooden axes.
This sucks.
Oh my god.
This is the worst addition ever to Minecraft.
Can I break this?
I can break the trial rule.
I can be like, I'm fucking out.
Oh, there's like beds and stuff.
There's like hidden beds.
What the hell are these?
Oh, weird.
They're not supposed to merge, right?
I don't think so.
I've never seen this before.
They're not supposed to merge, right?
Are they supposed to merge?
Like, is this supposed to happen?
No, someone said it's not supposed to.
Someone literally said it's not supposed to.
Oh my god.
I'm filing a complaint with Minecraft right now.
Why?
Why is there a seed?
What was the seed?
I posted it in our chat.
You can post it.
This is the seed for anybody who wants to explore.
Have fun.
Have fun in this hellhole.
I'm gonna...
Enjoy.
Have fun.
I'm just...
I'm gonna delete this world.
I'm deleting this world.
Oh, this is the outside of the trials.
Oh my god.
This is the newest version.
And the trials are huge.
Like, it's humongous.
It never ends.
I'm gonna sleep through the night.
Good night.
Where did you go?
I don't know.
I'm going back to spectate.
I need to know where I...
Where I went to.
Oh my god.
Just a bunch of potatoes.
Why is the loot in here so terrible?
Oh my god.
What was the point of being in the trials?
What was the point?
Where is the ender?
I don't even know.
I'm going to the ender dragon.
I'm fucking...
How are you going to the ender dragon?
I'm going to the ender dragon.
I...
How do I go to the end?
How do I...
How do I teleport to you?
You have to probably go to the eye and then put in the things and then go to the dragon.
I'm going in.
Get this shit out of here.
Get this shit out.
You got all my stuff?
No.
I'm fucking in creative mode.
I'm in creative.
Can you change my mode?
Since you're admin.
I can.
Game mode.
Creative.
There we go.
Yeah!
I'm back!
I'm back, baby!
Get the eye.
Get the eye and put it in.
We suffered enough.
This is so fucked up.
Oh wait.
We're in the worst spot.
This is so...
Come on.
Let's go beat this fucker.
Netherite sword.
Hold on.
We're doing it.
No!
You don't get to have that.
You don't get to have that either.
Or this one.
What the fuck is this?
Kill him!
Oh wait, there's one more.
Why?
What was the point of everything we did?
What was the point?
When you put us down!
Oh he's about to do his thing.
Do your fucking thing now.
Do it.
Oh you're charging.
This is so cathartic right now.
Die!
You gotta die!
Ender Dragon, die!
Everything, screw you, screw this whole world.
Everybody in this world deserves to die.
I know.
Oh my god, please.
Cease to exist.
Cease to exist, come on!
Just a little bit more!
Guys,
we did it.
We beat the Ender Dragon.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
I'm crying.
This is not meant for men.
Oh my god.
I can't believe...
I can't believe it ends.
Even if we somehow managed to survive all of that.
Seriously, I thought our luck was turning around when I just happened to come across the fortress.
I was like, oh my god, wait.
This is actually doable.
We can do this.
And then...
Everything.
Oh my god.
The entire...
The entire cosmos was against this run.
It's true.
Oh my god.
How did we get this seed?
How did we get it?
If only we didn't throw it in the beginning.
We would've had the best...
We...
All the other seeds we had started out so well.
And then we were like, you know what?
We're just gonna fight with this one.
We got this.
We can finally sleep.
I'm glad we toughened it out to just see what it was like at the end.
Just to see...
I think if tomorrow...
If we went to bed and we were like, let's do the end and try it tomorrow.
That we would not have survived.
No, we wouldn't have survived.
No.
It would've been the fastest second stream.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It was rigged from the start.
I'm glad that we have all of that on camera.
Just...
Just the...
Me going...
Finding the stronghold and then being like, what the...
Wait, the trials...
The trials are connected.
No!
And they were like, it's not supposed to merge.
It's not supposed to merge.
But yet, somehow...
I like how someone was like, you shouldn't have cheated.
After everything we've been through...
We can't even have this.
We played fair the entire time.
We didn't even give you the seed.
We tried so hard.
Trying to figure this out ourselves.
And now you're like, you shouldn't have cheated.
Seeds get degrees.
And you know what letter cheater starts with?
We needed this.
It was so cathartic.
Killing the dragon after everything we've been through.
I can't believe the trials.
The trials would have killed us.
If anything.
Oh my god.
Someone just said the seed cheated first.
Yes!
The seed cheated first!
It was all the seed's fault.
Oh my god.
Even chat was like, give us the seed.
We'll find the fortress for you.
No, no.
You guys need to sleep.
Go to bed.
Just do it tomorrow.
If we did this tomorrow, this would have hurt even more.
I know, right?
This would have hurt even more.
If we went to bed and tried to do this tomorrow.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, someone made a good point too.
You don't even know what the trials look like.
So you would have just walked right in.
Here's the seed, everybody.
Seed of this world.
I'll post it again.
If you guys want to try and do the seed of this world.
I'll pin it.
Here you go, everybody.
Enjoy, have fun.
I think this is the most us ending.
Only we could have conjured this to happen.
After literally all the bullshit we went through.
Everything.
The perfect ending.
It truly was.
Oh gosh, okay.
I'll see you next week.
Next time when we do it legit.
Oh yeah.
We will try it legitimately again sometime.
We'll try.
We just need to recover from this.
When we wanted to do this...
We didn't think this was gonna happen.
We didn't think we would...
We would go through such pain.
For those who wanted the coordinates of the stronghold.
I pressed F3.
When we were exploring the trial room.
So just find that in the VOD.
I'm done.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna go to sleep now.
I have like this rush of adrenaline.
That I didn't expect.
I did too.
When we found the trial rooms.
I woke the fuck up.
I was filled with so much anger.
And disbelief.
It was like after...
We spent like an hour prepping.
For the ender dragon.
While we were sleep deprived.
We spent an hour just leveling up.
Just not to know.
That it was just unwinnable in the end.
It was never winnable.
You know what's probably the case too.
Is that like stronghold.
That your chat mentioned.
That you passed over.
Probably was way easier.
Probably was a proper struggle.
And we got sent.
We got sent to the bullshit one.
We followed the eyes.
Just to be here.
No, I'm deleting this scene.
We're starting on a new scene.
When we're doing this again.
You were starting on a new scene.
We're not doing this again.
I'm deleting the world.
They're telling us to wake up.
We haven't even gone to sleep yet.
Wake up.
I lost my dogs in this scene.
Twice.
One of them.
We had that weird glitch.
That sent us back.
I woke up and they were gone.
They never existed.
In my life.
My first dog just disappeared.
How do I escape from the...
Oh, there we go.
I'm back.
Where are you?
I'm in the fucking...
I'm in the bed.
I'm in the trial.
I never left.
I never left hell.
I'm back in our...
In this initial spawn point.
Are you coming to me?
I'll come to you.
I'm here.
Oh my god.
Let's see where the Eye of Ender takes us now.
Come on, Eye of Ender.
Take us to a better...
Are you serious?
No, it's still going.
Yeah, it's still going.
Where are you?
I'm following the eye.
I'm gonna TP to you again.
I hate this seed.
I wanna burn everything down.
I hate this seed so much.
I want it.
I hate this seed.
Oh, it's right here.
Wait, is it?
No, it's right here.
Oh, never mind.
It's still going.
It's right here.
Just keep going.
I wanna know what a good stronghold actually looks like.
I wanna know.
We're going.
We just wanna set the world on fire.
We just wanna know.
What's it called?
What's what called?
Slash...
Locate...
Structure...
Strong...
Minecraft...
1506 blocks away.
150...
You can...
You can grab...
Yeah, I'm burning everything.
I'm burning it.
It deserves it.
I'm just going...
I'm going spectator mode.
I'm fucking...
I can't change my mode, so I'm stuck in creative.
Okay.
It's fine.
Where is this hellhole?
Where is the second hellhole?
Burn.
Min is burning...
Burning it all down.
Burninating the countryside.
Burninating the piggies.
Burninating everything inside.
And all the cottages.
Little cottages.
It didn't load.
What didn't load?
The stronghold.
Stronghold.
Oh, look.
Another trout.
Oh, we broke it.
Game mode.
Creative.
Wait, teleport me to you.
How do I...
How do I teleport to you?
Wait, no, not yet.
Don't do it yet.
I fucking broke it.
What do you mean you broke it?
What did you break?
I teleported somewhere, but it's not working.
Uh-oh.
Okay, cursed seed.
I'm leaving, I'm leaving, I'm leaving.
Where am I?
Game mode.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm trying to find it.
I'm trying to find the other stronghold.
Where is it?
It literally gave you the coordinates.
Just click it.
And then it'll...
And then it took me to some...
It fucked up.
What?
Like here?
Is this the same area?
No.
Oh my god.
It took us to...
There's the trials.
This is...
No way.
There's...
Wait, teleport me, teleport me, teleport me.
The stronghold had another trial.
Teleport me, teleport me.
Teleport me.
Okay, okay.
No fucking way.
Are you serious?
Put me in spectator mode.
Okay, and then...
Game mode, spectator.
Look down.
Oh wait, did you...
Oh no, I brought the server.
Hold on, we can go back in, we can go back in.
Okay, okay, wait.
I'm waiting for the server to come back.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in.
Okay, the...
The stronghold had...
Oh my god.
Where are we?
Okay, okay, I'm gonna locate...
Locate structure...
Stronghold.
The...
The other...
The other one...
Had one too.
Are you sure it's not the same one?
No, no it's not.
I know it's not.
Oh wait, I'm already in spectator.
Okay, wait.
I know it's not, that's the thing.
Oh wait, I'm not in spectator anymore.
Teleport me.
Give me a sec, I'm trying to head to the...
Okay, it's like...
Game mode...
Spectator.
I need to go to spectator to find this again.
Okay, I found...
So...
Oh my god, there's no way!
I am wide awake now.
I don't know how I'm gonna get to sleep.
It's a different stronghold.
It's a different one.
Okay.
Game mode...
Creative...
Okay, wait, sorry.
Game mode, not creative.
Spectator.
Go down, look down.
Look down, look down.
Oh my god!
We have to go through...
We have to go through the trials!
Through the trials!
To get to the stronghold!
Oh...
My god.
And it is a different one.
This is not the same one!
The stronghold is below!
The fucking trials!
They're like, you will do the trials.
No matter where you go...
You will do the trials.
You will get away.
Oh my god!
You will never leave.
This is the...
Did you find the eye?
Where is it?
Wait, is it below?
Oh yeah, it's below.
Where even is it?
The eye is...
Oh wait, that's just a...
The eye!
I can't even tell.
Where is the eye?
I found the bookshelf.
Yeah, I see all the...
Where is it?
Huh?
Where is the eye?
Is it this?
Is it not?
There's no portal.
There's no portal room.
Wait.
There's no way.
I think this is supposed to be the portal room.
And it's just a random...
Wait, what?
It's just like a random...
It's like a random...
I think this is supposed to be the portal room.
I got eaten by a geode.
Oh my god.
Wait, there has to be...
Maybe we passed it.
Oh, I found it!
Oh my god.
It also has no eyes in it though.
I thought that was insane.
Oh my god.
That would have been absolute cinema.
Oh, is it?
Oh my god.
It also has no eyes.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Wait, where did it go?
I found it and I lost it.
It's so easy to lose.
Oh my god.
Where did it go?
It's so far away.
It's so far away, right?
It's like past the trials.
Why is this...
Why is this trial so fucking big?
I hate this scene.
I'm so fucking awake.
It feels like someone purposefully made this.
Like, this wasn't randomly generated.
This was the one...
Notch came back just to make this scene.
And he's like, one day...
someone is gonna hit that scene once.
Oh my god.
Wait, what's the nether like...
for this one too?
No, there's no way it would be that bad, right?
You're going to the nether too?
I can't even find...
No, not nether.
I meant the eye.
Oh, I can't find the eye.
Hold on, I'm gonna teleport to you.
Okay.
Place the eyes in there.
Let's see how bad this spawn is.
Oh, they're the same?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It was just the seed.
It was just the seed that gave us the fucking terrible...
Alright, it didn't matter.
It didn't fucking matter.
Apparently, it's the same spawn.
It's the same end spawn.
Wow.
It's just the seed.
It's based off of all the seeds.
Wow.
I have no words.
I have no words for this.
Wait, where did the trials disappear to?
Where is this?
It's the other side.
It's the opposite side of the fucking portal.
Oh my god, they're like not even connected.
What is this stronghold?
What is this?
What?
You have to go like all the way over...
all the way here?
For the eye?
How do you get here?
What do you mean?
It's like not connected properly.
It's bonkers.
Oh my god.
I don't even know how you get to this.
What?
It's not connected with the portal area.
It's like you go down here...
and then you're in a dead end...
but you have to mine...
but it's like you have to know...
what walls to knock down.
It's amazing we got this far.
It's actually...
It's actually amazing that we got this far.
It's amazing we didn't make it.
We were never meant to make it to the stronghold.
No we weren't.
We were never meant to.
GGs Mint.
GGs Doki.
I'm glad we stuck it up...
just to see this hellhole that we made.
I know.
You know what?
Maybe dying right before seeing that atrocity...
just brought inner peace to me.
What?
I think it's just...
I think if we rested and tried this tomorrow...
we would've been even more angry.
I know.
We would've realized...
we were well rested just to find out...
it was always against us.
We were never meant to...
We were never meant to beat...
And with how...
far away the stronghold was still...
from where I died...
I think it would've taken us another hour...
or so to find it.
At least.
It's just...
Oh my god.
The drown with the trident...
was just like...
I'm saving you.
Don't keep going.
Don't do it.
I'm putting you out of your misery.
It's over.
Turn back.
Oh my god.
Thank you everybody for...
going on this journey with us.
Wild adventure.
I can't wait to do this again.
The sun is literally up so I'm going to go...
attempt some sleep for a couple of hours.
Me too.
I have dance lessons later.
Oh my god.
GG everyone.
We're both going to head to bed now.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye.
Remember to check out our tickets by the way.
Everybody check out the concert.
If we sell out we'll play...
Minecraft in 3D.
We'll do this scene in 3D.
We'll do the scene again in 3D.
We have the...
scene numbers anyway.
If we sell out...
the concert we'll do this exact scene...
in 3D.
GG's everybody.
Bye bye.
Hold on.
Can I send you this real quick?
Look at this tweet.
Mio, I mean...
I just saw your tweet.
This is insane.
We really managed to...
Look at this.
Look at this tweet.
I hate this so much.
Holy shit.
How?
How is this possible?
No fucking way.
Oh my god.
I'm leaving.
I'm done.
Good night everybody.
Or good morning.
Bye.
Bye bye.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
This was so much fun.
Otsumito.
I'm gonna go nap.
I'm gonna still try...
and wake up at...
my normal time.
10.
So we'll see how that works.
That was fun.
That was silly.
What a time.
Only we could do that, right?
Thanks guys.
Thank you.
Otsumito.
Bye bye.